>> Tucker: WE ARE GOING TO
LEARN MORE.
>> YOU ARE WELCOME.
>> Tucker: END AMERICA'S
TROOP PRESENCE IN SYRIA.
MISSION WAS TO DEFEAT ISIS,
ISIS HAS BEEN CRUSHED.
TIME TO DECLARE VICTORY AND
GO HOME.
MAKE SENSE?
NO.
NOT IN WASHINGTON.
PEOPLE HERE LOST CONTROL.
AMERICA IS NOT ALLOWED TO
WITHDRAW FROM ANY PLACE
EVER, WHEREVER AMERICAN
TROOPS GO.
THEY MUST REMAIN UNTIL THE
END, WHENEVER THAT IS.
>> WELL, THERE ARE SO MANY
FOOLISH THINGS THIS MAN HAS
DONE.
BUT THIS RANKS PRETTY HIGH.
>> A DECISION THAT IS
DANGEROUS.
AND A DECISION THAT IS A
CHRISTMAS PRESENT TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> GIVING A HUGE CHRISTMAS
PRESENT TO PUTIN AND TO
IRAN.
>> I COULDN'T DISAGREE MORE
WITH HIS DECISION.
IT IS A TERRIBLE DECISION.
>> I THINK THIS WILL BE
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE WORST
FOREIGN POLICY BLUNDERS OF
THIS CENTURY.
>> Tucker: THESE PEOPLE ARE
TOO DUMB TO GOVERN.
THEY ARE GOVERNING
NONETHELESS.
THEY WILL GET THEIR WAY
POTENTIALLY DESPITE THE FACT
THAT NONE OF THEM IS
PRESIDENT.
ONLY PRESIDENT THE DECIDES
WHAT OUR TROOPS DO BUT THEY
MAY WIN.
RECENTLY SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM OF SOUTH CAROLINA
BOASTED THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAD BEEN CONVINCED TO
WITHDRAW TROOPS FROM SYRIA.
NO DOUBT THE NEXT OBJECTIVE
IS MAKING THAT PAUSE
PERMANENT.
WHAT NEXT?
DOUGLAS MCGREGOR WATCHES
CLOSELY.
MARCH TO THE VICTORY HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN CIVILIAN
CONTROL THE MILITARY IT,
SHOULD BE AS SIMPLE AS THE
PRESIDENT SAYING THIS IS
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE THAT
SIMPLE.
>> NO.
I THINK THERE IS A PROBLEM
YOU GOT TO REMEMBER THAT
MOST OF YOUR SENIOR OFFICERS
ARE PRODUCTS OF THE CLINTON,
BUSH, OBAMA AREA.
THEY HAVE A LOT INVESTED IN
THIS.
REMEMBER, THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN THE SEVEN ZIP
CODES IN AND AROUND
WASHINGTON, D.C. HAVE ALL
BECOME MILLIONAIRES AS A
RESULT OF THEIR INVESTMENT
IN THESE FAILED OPERATIONS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT A
TALKING POINT.
THAT'S LITERALLY TRUE.
>> YES, OF COURSE.
YOU PUT THE TWO TOGETHER,
YOU HAVE A LOT OF RESISTANCE
TO ENDING SOMETHING THAT'S
PROFITABLE FOR THEM.
IT HASN'T BEEN PROFITABLE
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S BEEN A DISASTER.
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN DEBT
IN THE LAST 17 YEARS.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE KILLED
AND WOUNDED AND FOR WHAT IN
THE ANSWER IS NOT MUCH.
>> Tucker: IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
A CRISIS, CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS OR SOMETHING THAT
WOULD UNDERMINE DEMOCRACY AS
WE PRACTICED FOR 240 YEARS,
IT'S THE IDEA OF UNELECTED,
THE UNELECTED SUBVERTING THE
POWER OF THE ELECTED, RIGHT?
ISN'T THAT DEMOCRATIC BY
DEFINITION.
>> SUPPORTED BY MANY OF THE
ELECTED TO SUPPORT DECISION
TO LEAD.
THERE IS ANOTHER PROBLEM
WITH THIS.
HISTORICALLY WHEN WE LEAVE
AS WE DID WHEN WE LEAVE
VIETNAM WHY ARE OUT
PERMANENTLY.
PEOPLE KNOW ONCE WE LEAVE
SYRIA.
ONCE WE GET COMPLETELY OUT
OF IRAQ.
OF AFGHANISTAN, IT'S OVER
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING
TO DO THAT, IT IS CLEAR.
THIS PAUSE IS JUST THAT IT
IS A PAUSE WE HAD TO GET OUT
OF NORTHERN SYRIA QUICKLY.
THEY WERE POISED ATTACK THE
KURDS.
ATTACKING IN NORTHERN SYRIA.
WE GOT THE SYRIAN GOVERNMENT
TO GO IN THERE AND WE GOT
OUT.
NOW WE HAVE CREATED AN
ENORMOUS PROBLEM FOR
MR. PUTIN.
MR. PUTIN HAS CULTIVATED THE
TURKS AND CULTIVATED HIS
IRANIAN AND SYRIAN ALLIES.
HE HAS TO MAKE A CHOICE.
DOES HE ALLOW THE TUCKERS
INTO SYRIA?
THEN HE LOSES HIS POSITIONS
WITH THE SYRIANS AND
IRANIANS.
SO THE NOTION THAT MR. PUTIN
HAS SOMEHOW ANOTHER WON
SOMETHING IS ABSURD.
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY CLEVER
MOVE ON THE PART OF THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: IF YOU SEE LIKE
SIX OR SEVEN SENATORS AND
TALKING HEADS IN A ROW
REPEELGT THE SAME TALKING
POINT LIKE ROBOTS.
THIS IS A CHRISTMAS PRESENT
FOR PUTIN.
THAT'S LIKE PRIMA FACIE
EVIDENCE THAT THEY ARE DUMB,
RIGHT?
>> YOU COULD SAY STUPID.
BUT OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE
BRIEFED BY ONLY ONE SIDE AND
THAT SIDE HAS NO INTEREST IN
THE TRUTH.
THE TRUTH IS BY GETTING OUT
OF WAY, WE HAVE ELIMINATED
THE CONSENSUS THAT WAS
HOLDING THESE VARIOUS
DIVERSE PARTNERS TOGETHER.
THERE IS NO REASONS WHY THE
TURKS, THE RUSSIANS, THE
IRANIANS SHOULD COOPERATE AT
ALL.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.